now the northern ireland secretary has
confirmed plans to introduce a statue of
limitations that would effectively end
all prosecutions related to crimes
committed during the troubles
the announcement by brandon lewis has
provoked anger among families who lost
loved ones during that period as well as
political parties in northern ireland
and the republic of ireland mr lewis
joins me now good evening thanks for
being with us i mean do you want to see
reconciliation in northern ireland
yes absolutely as i outlined in
parliament today
what we want to see is an information
recovery process that gets to
the information that families in too
many cases have either waited too long
for
or not had at all that gets the truth
and through that accountability
a wider ability for northern ireland to
talk about this as part of the old
history as this is all part of the
principles
of what was in the storm and house
agreement and reconciliation for wider
society in northern ireland so that we
can start
and people in northern ireland can start
to be looking forward whilst always
being very alert to
and aware of what has gone before right
but doesn't reconciliation
require justice and aren't you now
depriving
uh the victims the families of justice
well this is a very difficult a complex
and sensitive issue and it's a painful
reality that we're
that i'm outlining today which is we are
seeing case after case that is
not just holding up the criminal justice
system and preventing people from
getting
information but it's also failing people
we've seen cases this year
that have consistently collapsed due to
the period of time we're seeing
very very good investigative processes
to operation canova for example
not reaching prosecutions but it is
getting for the families
to the truth of what happened i think
there's lessons to learn in that
around what information recovery can be
and how it can be done in a way that
really does
deliver for people and yes while you're
right we do need to see reconciliation
and it goes more widely than than than
just this it's also looking at the
future looking at a society that since
the belfast good friday agreement that
looked to have integrated education
going through northern ireland still
today some only seven percent of people
experience
integrated education and for the
long-term future we need to look at that
as part of
how we reconcile for the whole wider
society yeah but this goes a lot
further than prosecutions you're ending
so-called legacy inquests and civil
actions that families have put their
faith in
36 inquests relating to the troubles i
think are due to be heard more than a
thousand
civil claims uh lodged against
many of them the ministry of defense i
mean put yourself in their position
if if you had a family heaven forbid a
family member or members murdered
in the troubles you would want
prosecutions wouldn't you you would want
certainly some answers oh
look absolutely we all want to see
answers and i think we also need to
recognize mark there's a wide
view good set of views around legacy and
information some families don't want to
revisit the past we obviously need to
respect that
as well but obviously there's a wide
number large number who still want
information about what happened that
they're not able to get to the current
system
is failing everybody and we're seeing as
many people would argue as the prime
minister airline today
vexatious claims and a cycle of
investigations that's not fair either
on the the wide range of our uh veterans
who served and now
security services have served in
northern ireland the vast majority not
only served with honour but put their
lives at risk to protect
others as well and we that's where we
come to this very
it is a painful difficult reality of
things in northern ireland
changed with the belfast good friday
agreement justice changed in terms of
the sentencing act that followed from
that
we're seeing in reality a lack of
prosecutions
but the criminal justice system
effectively getting in the way
of accountability and truth and
information we want to see a really
robust
strong information recovery process the
one that is
the parlance is often article two
compliant that fulfills our
international
obligations to get to the truth of what
happened yeah but i mean
also you've got the families of those
killed by soldiers
um certainly in west belfast
one thinks of bally murphy what would
you say to justice keegan
who said after the inquest findings i
think it was in may
this was a war crime and must be and
people must be held to account
well i agree one of the things we want
to do is make sure that there is
accountability that's why i'm very clear
about that
the importance of a strong information
recovery process that gets to truth
information and accountability
and bala murphy which i i spoke about at
the time is a
is a very good example of how families
have been failed
it took 50 years for those families to
get to the truth of what happened to
their loved ones it shouldn't
happen that way and that's what i mean
by the current system is failing
everybody and we need to find a
different way forward the belfast good
friday agreement was a big step at the
time
this is a big step we're asking people
to take and what we've done today is
publish a command paper outlining
the three core principles behind this
and what we can deliver
and just want to engage with people in
the weeks ahead around that yeah so what
would you say
to the family member we interviewed this
afternoon who said that
your announcement was obscene and
abhorrent to our ears
and then went on to say that it sounds
like the sole purpose of the legislation
is to
cover up state crimes
well i do understand why people have
lost loved ones or been injured
themselves are victims of this and let's
not forget
a lot of our own veterans are victims
from the troubles as well or
are close to victims of the troubles
this is something that works
across society and we've got to be very
honest with people about the reality of
where we are we've seen consistently
just this year alone
cases failing to be able to be
prosecutable because of the period of
time that has passed
and yet that in one case 11 years since
there was a finding of some culpability
11 years of a process that failed both
the veterans and it found
the victim's family that isn't good for
society
that isn't getting to accountability for
people because those cases are
collapsing we want to find a way
that really does help families get
information get understanding and truth
and accountability
okay brandon lewis appreciate your time
thanks very much